la francilienne à la cote environ quatre
mille concurrents aujourd'hui pour cette
course de cyclotourisme amateurs 285 km
autour de l'île de france à parcourir en
13h45 maximum les mois entraînions qui
adoptaient des formules plus facile de
niffer des christian welter pour 4000
fanas de cyclotourisme la francilienne
94 et la mecque de la randonnée à vélo
civile départs et arrivées dans les
yvelines l'essonne le val-d'oise et la
seine-et-marne et cette formule route et
vtt pour satisfaire tout le monde
des itinéraires qui n'effraie pas les
papilles de la [ __ ] on est parti hier
ont fait le tour complet quoi on deux
jours c'est à dire combien de kilomètres
290 300 avec la déviation seraient 300
maintenant puis alors ce qui est
agréable c'est de voir l'île de france
dans sa perte preuve qu'on ne connaît
pas qu'on ne connaît pas la région
il ya encore des petites routes sympa
sans être bousculé absolument découvert
beaucoup de choses et on a envie d'y
retourner et vous fait ça tous les
week-ends nous c'est d'autres exploits
les plus chevronnés ont avalé 285 km en
14h environ à la moyenne de 20 km heure
d'autres l'ont parcourue à leur rythme
en découvrant les trésors de la région
sans oublier les vététistes épris de
chemins secrets à l'écart des circuits
traditionnels
tous ont participé à la grande fête du
vélo écolo en vallée de chevreuse dans
forêts de montmorency de saint germain
ou à saint-marc ozoir et vert-le-grand
une balade des cyclos heureux sur les
petites routes et à travers les bourdes
ile de france
bref la grande évasion pour tous les
amoureux de la petite reine